guarda che se mia madre nel video pop up
è bellissimo ora tutti ragazzi e
benvenuti questo video sono fa vj e
siamo tornati oggi su youtube white che
il videogioco degli youtubers per chi
non avesse visto il primo episodio il
gioco anzi il documentario che illustra
come vive uno youtuber che fa un video
giorno era arrivato a 5.000 iscritti
prima roba della giornata un video era
almeno da una settimana che non ci
giocava ragazzi quindi dovrei prenderci
un attimo la mano usate che non ho
giocato per un po ma ci sono di nuovo
ecco perfetto sarà un successo
assicurato sto video hai trovato un
oggetto segreto singing comment l'aver
che dovrei mettermi a cantare perché
video quali di 80 miglia new record
regal white tai chi che c'è su tizio
giorno è una tipa ragazzi come che tutta
sta [ __ ] entra nella mia stanza non è
mai successo a sta cosa anzi ecco
infatti adesso sono triste perché ho
capito che mi sta prendendo per il culo
è entrata un'altra donna non queste mia
madre e mia madre ma [ __ ] shira partner
vorresti essere mio compagno di stanza a
[ __ ] se c'è una [ __ ] che mi ha chiesto
di andare a vivere con lei ma non è mai
successa questa cosa devi pagare
anzi è io pago in natura è va bene
promesso vengo cioè nel senso arrivo
vabbè è capito quando devo andare a
vivere con questa cogli l'occasione uomo
fatte da chiara e una chiamata
chiamala mi piaci ma ma non voglio che
la relazione continui se non ci vediamo
di persona la [ __ ] poi vide
began e le altre
i ragazzi e benvenuti in questo video
sarò pari j e vabbè con rating
partiamo subito con una cosa così una
tipa morta che ci al maestro sul letto
singin comment daje daje montiamo lo
questo video io sono bravo a montare i
video che regala fatto questa 8 fatto un
video della madonna
se come video quality nono 176 editing
110 pubblici video blogs cazzo sbloccati
vlog ai sbloccato il nuovo tipo di video
i blog sono i video più visti e a
facciamo blog a manetta ma ci sono anche
le statistiche ma non ci ho parole mai
ma quanto figo questi sono troppo e
troppi iscritti troppo famosi io non
sono gay sono tutto scarso io sono
ultimo facciamo video cui the show noto
i big show 6 profile contatta contattalo
che facciamo i video non puoi fare
collaborazione ma [ __ ] chattiamo
con la tipa dove tra tipico e veri
possiamo chiedergli di uscire invita a
casa ai miti del sta arrivando la storia
ndola tipa arrivando attiva ciao bella
gnocca
grazie per l'invito e lo fa vj si sa che
una si presenta a casa mia e mi chiama
fa vj e non lorenzo che scende tutto
però a piedi una abbraccia che bella
l'affluenza senti zia e io vorrei no che
cosa fai
qual è la mia finestra non puoi ancora
suicidarti parliano quello è un
televisore flirt a è interessata ma no
macao è che io provavo a essere gentile
talk talk parla parla recupera ma che
cazzo fai video senti e posso chiederti
un appuntamento dei die un regalo cosa è
no ho speso dei soldi io volevo andarlo
a rubare il regalo che cazzo
[Musica]
che roma avanti c'è chi è la mia france
non può durare ma un certo limite quindi
levati dar cat
rega non ma cagato di pezza
va bene ragazzi niente da fare va faccio
un altro video poi vado a dormire perché
mi chiama data mortacci sua la prossima
volta ragazzi proviamo a fare i blog
quella tra mi ha respinto le femmine
puzzano ecco ho fatto il video
incazzatura perché ti ho chiesto solo un
appuntamento e manco l'appuntamento mai
dato la madonna che video quality 111 è
perfetto
che cosa vuoi donna ma non ho tempo di
studiare devo trovare una ragazza che se
no non posso fare il video insieme a lei
e non prendo le views prima di andare a
dormire qui fare shopping un secondo che
voglio comprare il gioco nuovo tv dei
commenti vi piace un sacco qual è il
commento negativo non dovresti fare
video se sei così stanco mi chiesta cosa
me l'hanno detto sul serio una volta
ricordo perché si vede che sono stanco
va bene allora prima vai ad una prima
vai a fare shopping
lo shopping lo puoi fare file out prendi
lo compra lo fai l'auto mi sta facendo
il video di quella [ __ ] mi ha respinto
mia madre sarà contenta che mi sono
impegnato nello studio el hout ragazze
ce la facciamo un altro gameplay da oggi
divento gay
evviva il gameplay è contento 221 di
contenuto 221 record assoluto nella
storia alla ragazzi solo a livello set
madonna quanto quanti quante vi usa ha
fatto colpito haifa vj vorrei fare un
video con vuoi fare un video con me sul
gioco ma non so ancora come registrarlo
evitarlo la vita dei soldi per far vito
con lui
stiller i cazzi va bene non ho capito io
starò barega trova bene
ho però arrivato gioco regala eccolo la
vita a casa non ho capito bene se il
tipo deve fare un video a casa mia
dentro casa mia ecco ciao zio come stai
bene come lo facciamo sto video la mia
prima collaborazione con uno sfigato
sarà con sei contento che faccio video
così ma devo aspettare finché il video
pubblicato ora c'è la tipo che mi ha
funzionato e c'è un tipo nella stanza no
no no no non è come sembra
ciao fa vj c'è una stessa stasera va
bene andiamo alla festa no che voi lo
mette la mano sul mio canale meno manda
tutto a [ __ ] a mi devo vestire per la
festa la maglia rosa rosa i pantaloni
rosa
ecco
un approccio vai vai all'evento vai
all'evento senti zio io ti lascio qua fa
i video io vado alla festa che c'è una
[ __ ] che mi ha invitato tu fai
tranquillamente video medio anche lui è
arrivato anche lui alla festa ma tu lo
devi fare video in camera mia
dov'è la tipa rivelativa eccola tens
quindi se ballo con le ore che c'è il
buttafuori quanto è figo il jungle style
o punk arnhem st93 giusto gioco anzi o
sei vestito come se fossi putin cioè la
maglietta rosa alla checco zalone quindi
sei keko putin chance 0 di rimorchiare
ma lei ha una birra quindi se ubriaca
c'è una possibilità adesso attacca di
gelosia parla con un'altra les sims
ingelosire ti darà la patata noi invece
contenta che io socializzi ma [ __ ]
non ha funzionato questa tattica di
gelosia quindi torna a danzare con lei
adesso prova a chiederle di uscire tanto
è ubriaca magari mi risponde di si regge
l'alcol meglio di me va bene senti zia
io me ne vado e stato bello grazie di
avermi invitato di non avermi neanche
abbracciato brutta troveremo bene di 160
dollari e depositarli in un nuovo
appartamento per poter vivere insieme
datemi i soldi e allora facciamo
pertanto i video stanno andando to
lavora di brutto tanto il video di video
stanno facendo un sacco di più insomma
un di civile scritti caso ma ho visto
mica tantissimo
basta sgridarmi che c'è una patata che
vada adorabili tanto me ne vado da
questa casa e [ __ ] o il giorno
degli esami che bello mi sono preparato
un sacco per sé esami quindi sarà
sicuramente un successo questa kick ass
perché entrano tipi in camera mia ancora
non ho capito la zia a voi invitarmi ad
un party va bene dopo l'esame per
festeggiare di più cioè non è l'essenza
ho preso di più nel senso che ho preso
di più di quanto voi pensiate accetto e
mia madre sarà contentissima ora come
mista per ritirare tutta la camera
che la mia vita grazie a mamma no non è
vero non è vero non è vero non lo può
fare
brutta strada ma [ __ ]
per quanto mi hai tenuto grazie grazie
di passarmi attraverso grazie a darmi
torto al monito che brava brava aveva
fallito i video
devo andarmene per forza ragazzi perché
basta madre e basta poi video prima che
si raggiunga sono riuscito a fare i
video prima che mi raggiungesse mi
facesse il cazziatone mia madre sta per
farmi il culo quindi registro bella vai
vai vai vai a cucinare vai mai cucina
guarda che mia madre nel video pop up è
bellissimo per tutti ragazzi e bambini
deve sono video show mia madre dietro
che sta per farmi un culo così però io
registro chissenefrega affani comment
non ci credo dai ma veramente faccio
stupida stage e ma va bene dai falli
comment facciamo un commento per mia
madre che sta dietro che sarà
sicuramente contenta di vedermi a
registrare questa operazione in genere
richiede delle ore tutto con mia madre
dietro la madre sta per farmi il culo
publics video e il subito dopo
mia madre vuoi chattare e veri si
aspetta con i più cazzia donne ciatto
finito grazie
vai lavorava sejore 30 dollari va bene
dopo queste ore ho raggiunto i soldi per
trasferirmi posso trasferirmi inflitti
moving out yes sembra arrivato al
momento di trasferirmi attraverso la
porta della mia stanza casa tua vai boom
non ci posso credere è veri aiutami a
portare la roba è veri ci trasferiamo
nella nostra nuova casa dove faremo
tanti figli e bambini e cose da ragazzi
conclude l'episodio di youtube birdlife
continuano nel prossimo che adesso
abbiamo una nuova casa quindi sarà una
bomba pazzesca
momento è un mi piace anche la pace di
facebook come nido trascrizione sui siti
amici
diamo subito dai ragazzi
[Musica]